everything we've been doing in linear
algebra so far you might be thinking as
it's kind of a more painful way of doing
things that you already knew how to do
you've already dealt with vectors or i
i'm guessing that some of you all have
already dealt with vectors in your
calculus or your precalculus or your
physics classes but in this video i hope
to show you something that you're going
to do in linear algebra that you've
never done before and that it would have
been very hard to do had you not i guess
been exposed to these videos but i'm
going to start with once again a
different way of doing something you
already know how to do so let me just
define some vector here
some vector instead of making them bold
i'll just draw it with the arrow on top
i'm going to define my vector to be i
can do it with the arrow on top where i
can just make it super bold i'm just
going to define my vector it's going to
be a vector in r2
let's just say that my vector is the
vector
1. if i were to draw it in standard
position it looks like this you go 2 to
the right and up 1
like that
that's my
right there that is my vector v
now if i were to ask you what are all of
the possible vectors i can create so let
me define a set
let me define a set
s
and it's equal to
all of the vectors i can create if i
were to multiply v times some constant
so i multiply some constant some scalar
times v times my vector v
and i'll just to maybe a little bit
formal i say such that
c
is a member and i don't want to write
c is a member of the real numbers
now what would be a graphical
representation of this set
well if we draw them on standard
position i mean c could be any real
number so if i were to multiply c could
be 2
if you know if c is 2
c
let me do it this way if i do 2 times
our vector i'm going to get the vector
4 2. let me draw that in standard
position 4 2 it's right there it's this
vector right there
that vector right there it's collinear
with this first vector it's along the
same line but it just goes out to
further too now i could have done
another i could have done 1.5 times our
vector v let me do that in a different
color
and maybe that would be
that would be what that would be 1.5
times 2 which is 3
1.5 where would that vector get me i'd
go 1.5 and then
i'd go 3 and then 1.5 i'd get right
there
and i could multiply it by anything i
could multiply
1.4999 times vector v and get right over
here i could do minus
.0001 times vector v let me write that
down i could do
0.001 times our vector v
and where would that put me it would put
me right a little super small vector
right there if i did minus .01 it'd make
a super small vector right there
pointing in that direction if i were to
do minus 10 i would get a vector going
in this direction that goes way like
that or it goes away like that but you
can imagine that if i were to plot all
of the vectors in standard position
all of them that that could be
represented by any c in real numbers
i'll essentially get
i'll you know i'll end up drawing a
bunch of vectors where their arrows are
all
lined up along this line right there and
all lined up in even the negative
direction let me make sure i
draw it properly
along that line
like that i think you get the idea so
it's a set of collinear vectors so let
me write that down it's a set
of co
linear
collinear vectors
and if we view if we view these vectors
as position vectors that you know that
this vector represents a point in space
in r2 you know this r2 is just
our cartesian coordinate plane right
here in every direction if we view this
vector as a as a position vector let me
write that down
as a position vector if we view it as
kind of a coordinate in r2
then this set if we visually represent
it as a bunch of position vectors it'll
be represented by this whole line over
here
it'll be represented by this whole line
over here and i want to make that point
clear because if i didn't if it's
essentially a line of slope 2 right your
rise sorry a slope one half your rise is
one
your rise is one for going over two but
i don't wanna go back to our algebra one
notation too much but i wanna make this
point that this line of of of slope two
that goes through the origin this is if
we draw all of the vectors in this set
as in their standard form or if we draw
them all as position vectors if i didn't
make that that clarification or that
qualification i could have drawn these
vectors anywhere right because i you
know this 2 this 4 2 vector i could have
drawn
i could have drawn over here
and then i you know to say that it's
collinear probably wouldn't have made as
much visual sense to you but i think
this collinearity of it makes more sense
to you if you say oh let's draw them all
in in standard form all of them start at
the origin and then their their their
tails are at the origin their heads go
essentially to the coordinate they
represent that's what i mean by their
position vectors they don't necessarily
have to be position vectors but for i
guess the visualization in this in this
video well let's stick to that
now i was only able to represent
something that goes through the origin
with this slope so you can almost view
that this vector kind of represented its
slope this was you almost want to view
it as a slope vector if you wanted to
tie it in to what you learned in algebra
one what if we wanted to represent other
lines that had that slope what if we
wanted to what if we wanted to represent
uh what the line that goes
the same line or i guess a parallel line
that goes through that point over there
the point
you know this is the point
two
comma four or if we're thinking in
position vectors we could say that point
is represented by the vector
that point is represented by the
vector
let me
that point is represented by the vector
i'm going to call that x
it's represented by the vector x and the
vector x is equal to 2
that point right there what if i want to
represent the line that's parallel to
this that goes through
that 0.24 so i want to represent this
line right here
i want to represent
i'll draw it as parallel to this as i
can
i think you get the idea and it just
keeps going like
that in every direction these two lines
are parallel
how can i represent the set of all of
these vectors or the drawn in standard
form or the vec all of the vectors that
if i were to draw them in standard form
would show this line
well you could think about it this way
if every one of the vectors that
represented this line
if i start with any vector that was on
this line and i add my x vector to it
and i add my x vector to it
i'll be i'll show up at a corresponding
point
on this line that i want to be at right
if i start if i take if i start let's
say that this is let's say i do negative
let's say i do negative 2 times
vector my original so minus 2 times my
vector v
that equaled what minus 2 minus 4 minus
2. so that's that vector there but if i
were to add x to it if i were to add my
x vector if i were to add
so if i were to do minus 2
times my vector v but i would add x to
it so plus x
i'm adding this vector 2 comma 4 to it
so from here i'd go right 2 and up 4 so
i'd go here or visually you could just
say heads to tail so i would go right
there so it would end up at a
corresponding point over there
i'll end up at a corresponding point
over there
so the set of all points so when i
define my set s as the set of all points
where i just multiply v times the scalar
i got this thing that went through the
origin but now let me define another set
let me define a set l
maybe l for line
that's equal to
the set of all vectors
where it's x
the vector x i can do it bolder i'll
just do an arrow on it plus
plus
some scalar i could use c but let me use
t because i'm going to call this a
parametrization
of the line
so plus some scalar t
times my vector v
where
or such that t could be any any member
of the real numbers
so what is this going to be this is
going to be this blue line if i were to
draw all of these vectors in standard
position i'm going to get my blue line
for example if i do minus 2 if this is
minus 2
times my vector v i get here then if i
add x i go there so the vector this
vector right here that has its endpoint
right there
its endpoint sits on that line i can do
that with anything if i go if i take
this vector this is some scalar times my
vector v and i add x to it i end up with
this vector
whose endpoint if i view it as a
position vector its endpoint dictates
some coordinate in the x y plane so
it'll look at that point so i can get to
any of these vectors
this is a set of vectors right here
and all of these vectors are going to
point they're essentially going to point
to something
when i draw them in standard form if i
draw them in standard form they're going
to point to a point
on that blue line now you might say hey
sal this was a really obtuse way of
defining a line i mean we do it in
algebra one where we just say hey you
know y is equal to mx plus b and we
figure out the slope by figuring out the
difference of two points and then we do
a little substitution and this is stuff
you learned in seventh or eighth grade
this was really straightforward why am i
defining this this obtuse set here and
and and you know making you think in
terms of sets and vectors and adding
vectors and the reason is is because
this is very general
this worked well in r2 so in r2
this was great i mean we just have to
worry about x's and y's but what about
the situation i mean notice in your
algebra class your your teacher never
really gave you told you much or at
least the ones i took about how to how
do you represent lines in three
dimensions and i mean maybe some classes
go there but they definitely didn't tell
you how you represent lines in four
dimensions or 100 dimensions and that's
what this is going to do for us
right here i defined x and v as as
vectors in r2 they're two dimensional
vectors but we can extend it to an
arbitrary number of dimensions
so let me just just to kind of hit the
point home let's do one more example in
r2
where it's kind of the classic algebra
problem where you need to find the
equation for the line or but here we're
going to call it the set definition for
the line let's say we have two vectors
let's say we have the vector
a
we have the vector
which i'll define as
you know let me just say it's
2 1 so if i were to draw in standard
form it's 2
that's my vector a right there
and let's say i have vector b
let me define vector
b
i'm going to define it as
i don't know let me define it as
3.
so my vector b 0 i don't move to the
right at all and i go up so my vector b
will look like that
my vector b now i'm going to say that
these are position vectors that they're
we draw them in standard form when you
draw them in standard form the their
endpoints represent some position so you
can almost view these as coordinate
points in r2 this is r2 i mean if i all
of these coordinate axes i draw going to
be r2 now what if i asked you give me a
parameterization
of the line that goes through these two
points so essentially i want the
equation you can if you're thinking in
algebra one terms
i want the equation for the line that
goes through
these two points
that goes through those two points
so the classic way you would have
figured out the slope and all of that
and then you'd have substituted back in
but instead what we can do is
we can say hey look this line that that
goes through both of those points
you can almost say that you know that
both of those vectors lie on i guess
that's a better both of these vectors
lie on this line
now what is the what vector can be
represented by that line or even better
what lie
what
what vector if i take any arbitrary
scalar multiple well this can can
represent any other vector on that line
and let me do it this way
what if i were to take so this is vector
b here what if i were to take b minus a
we learned in i think it was the
previous video that b minus a you'll get
this vector right here
you'll get the difference in the two
vectors this is the vector
b
minus the vector a and you just think
about it what do i have to add to a to
get to b i have to add b minus a
so if i can get the vector b minus a
right and we know how to do that we just
subtract the vectors and then multiply
it by any scalar
then any scalar then we're going to get
any point along that line
we have to be careful so what happens if
we take
t so some scalar times our vector
times the vectors b minus a
b
minus a
what do we get then so b minus a looks
like that but if we were to draw it in
standard form remember this in standard
form b minus a would look something like
this
it would look something like this
right it would start at zero it'd be
parallel to this and then from zero we'd
draw its endpoint so if we just
multiplied some scalar times b minus a
we would actually get we would actually
just get
right we would get points or vectors
that lie on this line
vectors that lie on that line right
there
now that's not what we set out to do we
wanted to figure out a an equation or a
parametrization if you will of this line
or this set
what's called the set l so we want to
know what that set is equal to so in
order to get there we have to start with
this
which is one of these which is this line
which is this line here and we have to
shift it and we could shift it either by
shifting it straight up we could add
vector b to it
so we could take this this line right
here and add vector b to it and so any
point on here would have its
corresponding point there so when you
add vector b essentially shifts it up
that would work so we could say we could
add vector b
add vector b to it and now all of these
points for any arbitrary t is a member
of the real numbers
will lie on this green line or the other
option we could have done is we could
have added vector a vector a would have
taken any arbitrary point here and
shifted it
that way right you would be adding
vector a to it but either way you're
going to get to the green line that we
cared about so you could have also
defined it as the set of vector a plus
this line essentially t times vector b
minus a
where t is a member of the reals now all
of this so my definition of my line
could be either of these things
the definition of my line could be this
set
or it could be this set
and all of this seems all very abstract
but when you actually deal with the
numbers it actually becomes very simple
it becomes arguably simpler than what we
did in algebra 1.
so this l for this particular case of a
and b
let's figure it out my line is equal to
let me just use the first example it's
vector b
so it's the vector 0
plus t
times the vector b minus a
what's b minus a
zero minus two is minus two
three minus one
is
two 4
t is a member of the reals
now if this still seems kind of like a
convoluted set definition for you i
could write it in terms that you might
recognize better if we want to plot
points if we call this the y-axis
and we call this
the x-axis and if we call this the
x-coordinate or maybe more properly that
the x-coordinate and call this the
y-coordinate then we can set up a parrot
we can set up an equation here this
actually is the x slope
with respect well i don't want to this
is the x coordinate that's the y
coordinate or actually even better
whatever actually let me be very careful
there this is this is always going to
revolve end up being coming some vector
l1 l2
right this this is a set of vectors and
any member of the set is going to look
something like this so you know this
could be
this could be you know l i so
this is the x coordinate and this
is the y coordinate
and just to get this coordinate
and just to get this in a form that you
recognize so we're saying that l is a
set of you know this vector x plus t
times this vector
t times this vector b minus a here if we
wanted to write it in kind of a
parametric form
we can say since this is what determines
our x
coordinate we would say that x
is equal to
zero
plus t times minus two or minus two
times t
and then we can say that y since this is
what determines our y coordinate
y
is equal to
three
plus
t times two plus two t so we could have
rewritten that first equation is just x
is equal to minus two t and y is equal
to
two t plus three
so if you watch the videos on parametric
equations this is just a traditional
parametric definition
of this line
this line right there
now you might have still viewed this as
sal this was a waste of time this was
convoluted you had to define these sets
and all of that but now i'm going to
show you something that you probably
well unless you've done this before i
guess that's true of anything but you
probably haven't seen in your
traditional
algebra class let's say i have two
points and this now i'm going to deal in
three dimensions so let's say i have one
vector i'll just call it point one
because these are position vectors so
it's called position one
and it's the point this is in three
dimensions let's make up some numbers
negative one two
seven
let's say i have point two and once
again this is in three dimensions so you
have to specify three coordinates this
could be the x the y and the z
coordinate
point two i don't know let's make it 0
and 4.
now what if i wanted to find the
equation of the line that passes to
through these two points in r3 so this
is an
r3 in r3
well i just said that the equation of
this
line so i'll just call that
or the the set of this line let me just
call this you know l
it's going to be equal to
we could just pick one of these guys
it's going to be it could be p1
the vector p1 these are all vectors be
careful here
the vector p1
plus some random parameter t this t it
could be time like you you learn when
you first learn parametric equations
times the difference of the two vectors
times
p
one and it doesn't matter what order you
take it so that's a nice thing too p1
minus
p2 it could be p2 minus p1 and then this
you know because this can take on any
positive or negative value
where
t is a member
of the real numbers
so let's apply it to these numbers let's
apply it right here what is p1 minus p2
p1
minus p2
is equal to
let me get some space here
p1 minus p2 is equal minus 1 minus 0 is
minus 1. 2 minus 3
is minus
one
seven minus four is three
so that thing is that vector and so our
line can be described as the set of
vectors that if you were to plot it
in standard position
it would be this set of position vectors
it would be p1 it would be we do that in
green it would be
-1 2
7 i could have put p2 there just as
easily
plus
plus t
times
times -1 minus 1 3
where or such that t
is a member of the real numbers
now this also might not be satisfying
for you you're like gee you know how do
i plot this in three dimensions where is
my x y's and z's and if you want to care
about x y's and z's let's say that this
is
let's say let me go down here
let's say that this is
the
z-axis this is the x-axis and let's say
the y-axis
it kind of goes into into our board like
this so the y-axis comes out like that
our y-axis comes out like that
so what you can view this and actually i
probably won't graph so
the determinant for the x-coordinate
just our convention is going to be
this term right here
so we can write that x let me write that
down so that term is going to determine
our x coordinate so we can write that x
is equal to -1
be careful with the colors -1
plus minus 1 times t plus minus 1 times
t
that's our x coordinate
now our y coordinate is going to be
determined by this part
of our vector addition because these are
the y coordinates so we could say that
our y coordinate
is equal to
i'll just write it like this 2
plus minus 1 times t minus 1 times t
and then finally
our z coordinate is determined by that
there and the t shows up because t times
3 or i could just put this t into all of
this so the z coordinate is equal to 7
plus
t times 3 or i could say plus 3
t
and just like that we have three
parametric equations and you know when
we did it in r2 i did a parametric
equation but we learned in algebra one
you could just have a regular y in terms
of x you don't have to have a parametric
equation but when you're dealing in r3
the only way to define a line is to have
a parametric equation if you have just
an equation with x's y's and z's if i
just have x plus y
plus z is equal to some number this is
not a line
not
a line we'll talk more about this in r3
this is a plane
this is a plane the only way to define a
line or a curve in three dimensions it's
you know if i wanted to describe the
path of a fly in three dimensions it has
to be a parametric equation or if i were
to you know if i shoot a bullet in three
dimensions and it goes in a straight
line it has to be a parametric equation
so these i guess we call it these are
the equations
of a line in three dimensions
so hopefully you found that interesting
and
i think this will be the first video
where you have an appreciation that
linear algebra can solve problems or
address issues that you've never solved
before i mean there's no reason why we
had to just stop at three three
coordinates right here we could have
done this with 50 dimensions we could
have defined a line in 50 dimensions or
the
uh the the set of vectors
that define a line that you know two
points sit on in 50 dimensions which is
very hard to visualize but we can
actually deal with it mathematically